PROFESSOR: So, what is the
wave function that we have?
We must have a wave
function now that
is symmetric, and built
with e to the k x, kappa x,
and into the minus kappa x.
This is the only possibility.
E to the minus of kappa
absolute value of x.
This is psi of x for
x different from 0.
This is-- as you
can quickly see--
this is e to get minus
kappa x, when x is positive,
A e to the kappa x,
when x is negative.
And, both of them decay.
The first exponential negative
is the standard decaying
exponential to the right.
The one with
positive-- well, here x
is negative as you go
all the way to the left.
This one decays case as well.
And, this thing plotted
is a decaying exponential
with amplitude A, like that.
And, a decaying exponential with
amplitude A, and a singularity
there, which is what
you would have expected.
So, this seems to be
on the right track--
it's a continuous wave function.
The wave function cannot
fail to be continuous,
that's a complete disaster to
show that an equation could not
be satisfied.
So, this is our
discontinuous wave function.
So, at this moment you
really haven't yet used
the delta function-- the delta
function with intensity alpha
down.
I should have made a comment
that it's very nice that alpha
appeared here in the numerator.
If it would have appeared
in the denominator,
I would be telling you that
I think this problem is not
going to have a solution.
Why?
Because if it appears
in the numerator,
it means that as the delta
function potential is becoming
stronger and stronger,
the bound state
is getting deeper and deeper--
which is what you would expect.
But, if it would be
in the numerator--
in the denominator--
as the potential gets
deeper and deeper,
the boundary is going up.
That makes no sense whatsoever.
So, it's good that
it appeared there,
it's a sign that things are
in reasonable conditions.
So, now we really have to
face the delta function.
And, this is a procedure you
are going to do many times
in this course.
So, look at it, and
do it again and again
until you're very
comfortable with it.
It's the issue of discovering
what kind of discontinuity
you can have with
the delta function.
And, it's a discontinuity
in the derivative,
so let's quantify it.
So, here it is-- we begin
with the Schrodinger equation,
again.
But, I will write now the
potential term as well.
The potential is plus v of x
psi of x equals E psi of x.
And the idea is to
integrate this equation
from minus epsilon to epsilon.
And, epsilon is supposed to
be a small positive number.
So, you integrate
from minus epsilon
to epsilon the
differential equation,
and see what it does to you in
the limit as epsilon goes to 0.
That's what we're
going to try to do.
So, what do we get?
If you integrate this, you
get minus h squared over 2 m.
And now, you have to integrate
the second derivative
with respect to x, which
is the first derivative,
and therefore this is
the first derivative
at x equal epsilon minus the
first derivative at x equals
minus epsilon.
This is from the first
term, because you integrate
d x d second d x squared
psi is the same thing
as d x d d x of d psi
d x between A and B.
And, the integral of a
total derivative is d
psi d x at B A--
I think people
write it like this--
A to B. Evaluate it at the
top, minus the evaluation
at the bottom.
Now, the next term is the
integral of psi times v of x.
So, I'll write it
plus the integral
from minus epsilon to epsilon
d x minus alpha delta of x psi
of x--
that's the potential.
Now, we use the delta function.
And, on the right hand
side this will be E times
the integral from minus epsilon
to epsilon of psi of x d x.
So, that's the differential
equation integrated.
And now, we're going
to do two things.
We're going to do some
of these integrals,
and take the limit
as epsilon goes to 0.
So, I'll write this minus
h squared over 2 m limit
as epsilon goes to 0 of d psi
d x at epsilon minus d psi d x
at minus epsilon plus.
Let's think of this integral.
We can do this integral,
it's a delta function.
So, it picks the value of
the wave function at 0,
because 0 is inside the
interval of integration.
That's why we integrate it
from minus epsilon to epsilon,
to have the delta
function inside.
So, you get an alpha
out, a psi of 0,
and that's what
this integral is.
It's independent of
the value of epsilon
as long as epsilon
is different from 0.
So, this gives you
minus alpha psi of 0.
And now, the last
term is an integral
from minus epsilon to
epsilon of the wave function.
Now, the wave function
is continuous--
it should be continuous--
that means it's finite.
And, this integral,
as of any function
that is not divergent from
minus epsilon to epsilon
as epsilon goes to 0, is 0.
Any integral of a function
that doesn't diverge
as the limits of
integration go to 0,
the area under
the function is 0.
So, this is 0--
the limit.
And this thing goes to
0, so we put a 0 here.
So, at this moment we got
really what we wanted.
I'll write it this way.
I'll go here, and I'll say
minus h squared over 2 m,
and what is this?
This expression says,
calculate the derivative
of the function a little
bit to the right of 0,
and subtract the derivative
of the function a little bit
to the left of 0.
This is nothing but the
discontinuity in psi prime.
You're evaluating for any
epsilon greater than 0--
the psi prime a little to
right, a little too the left,
and taking the difference.
So, this is what we should call
the discontinuity delta at 0--
at x equals 0.
And, this and this is for
discontinuity of psi prime at x
equals 0 minus alpha
psi of 0 equals 0.
And from here, we discover
that delta zero psi prime
is equal to minus 2 m alpha
over h squared psi of 0.
This is the
discontinuity condition
produced by the delta function.
This whole quantity is what
we call delta 0 of psi prime.
And, what it says is that
yes, the wave function
can have a discontinuous
first derivative if the wave
function doesn't vanish there.
Once the wave function
doesn't vanish at that point,
the discontinuity
is in fact even
proportional to the value of
the wave function at that point.
And, here are the constants
of proportionality.
Now, I don't think it's worth
to memorize this equation
or anything like that,
because it basically
can be derived in a few lines.
This may have looked like
an interesting or somewhat
intricate derivation,
but after you've done
is a couple of times--
this is something
you'll do in a minute or so.
And, you just integrate
and find the discontinuity
in the derivative--
that's a formula there.
And, that's a formula
for a potential,
minus alpha delta of x.
So, if somebody gives you
a different potential,
well, you have to change
the alpha accordingly.
So, let's wrap this up.
So, we go to our case.
Here is our situation.
So, let's apply this.
So, what is the value?
Apply this equation
to our wave function.
So, what is the
derivative at epsilon?
It's minus kappa A E to
the minus kappa epsilon.
That's the derivative of
psi on the positive side.
I differentiated the top
line of this equation
minus the derivative
on the left side--
this one, the derivative.
So, this is kappa A E
to the kappa epsilon--
no, kappa minus epsilon again.
So, that's the left hand side.
The right hand side would be
minus 2 m alpha h squared psi
at 0.
Psi at 0 is A, so
that's what it gives us.
And we should take the
limit as epsilon goes to 0.
So, this is going
to 1, both of them.
So, the left hand side
is minus 2 kappa A,
and the right hand side is
2 m alpha over h squared A.
So, the 2--
it's also minus, I'm sorry--
so the 2s cancel,
the A cancels--
you never should have expected
to determine A unless you tried
to normalize the wave function.
Solving for energy
eigenstates states will never
determine A. The Schrodinger
equation is linear,
so A drops out, the
minus 2 drops out,
and kappa is equal to
m alpha over h squared.
So, that said that's great
because kappa is just
another name for the energy.
So, I have kappa m
alpha over h squared,
so that's another
name for the energy.
So, let's go to the energy.
The energy is h bar
squared kappa minus h bar
squared kappa squared over 2 m.
So, it's minus h bar squared.
Kappa squared would be m squared
alpha squared h to the fourth,
and there's a two m.
All these constants.
So, final answer.
E, the bound state energy is
minus m alpha squared minus m
alpha squared.
The m cancels it over h
squared minus one half.
So, back here the units worked
out, everything is good,
and the number was
determined as minus one half.
That's your bound state
energy for this problem.
So, this problem is instructive
because you basically
learn that in delta functions,
with one delta function
you get a bound state.
If you have two delta functions,
you may get more bound states--
three, four-- people
study those problems,
and you will investigate the
two delta function cases.